PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
Today we're going to do
a couple of exercises
on computing average values
and probabilities using
integration.
So for this problem,
I'm going to let
R be the name of
the region that's
bounded above by the
curve, by the line I guess,
y equals x and below by
the curve y equals x cubed.
So I have a little
picture of R here.
It, you know, lives all in
the first quadrant there.
It's just this little sliver.
So the first part
of the question
is, if I look at
all the points in R,
what's that average
x-coordinate of those points?
What's the average value
of the x-coordinate?
And the second problem is,
if I choose a point at random
somewhere in R,
what's the probability
that its x-coordinate
is larger than 1/2?
So what's the
probability that it lies
on the right-hand side of R?
So why don't you
pause the video,
take a couple minutes to
work through these problems,
come back, and we can
work on them together.
Alright, welcome back.
So hopefully you've had a chance
to get some good work done
on these questions.
So let's start to
work through them.
So remember, to compute the
average value of a function
over some region
what you need to do
is you need to compute
a weighted average.
And the weighting here is that
you have to consider the fact
that, you know, for
x very near zero,
there aren't very many points
in R in this little corner.
Right?
And for x very near
1, there aren't
very many points there either.
In the middle, this
region is a little higher,
so there are more points there.
So those points
will sort of weigh
more when you take the
average of all points,
than the points near the edges.
So the way we account for
that is we have this weight
function that is
the, in our case,
since we're interested in
the x-coordinate, the weight
at a given x-coordinate
is the slice
of the-- how much of the region
lies above that x-coordinate.
What, you know, the area of
a little rectangle above that
x-coordinate says, tells
you how many of the points
have that x-coordinate.
So then we want to average
the function x, right?
Because we're interested
in the x-coordinate,
so the function
we're averaging is x.
Over this region,
with that weighting.
So, all right, so let's
write down what that means.
So we have-- want average
of the function f of x,
and f of x, the thing we're
computing the average of
is, just the x-coordinate, so
it's just the function value x.
Over R. So we want the
average of this function, f
of x, over R. So what
we need to compute
is the-- so we have two
integrals we need to compute.
We need one integral
that is the numerator,
and so that numerator--
so I'm going
to just write average for
the average that we want.
So the numerator is
the integral-- OK,
and so we have to
integrate, we have
to take all possible
x-values into consideration.
So x going, in this case
that's x going from 0 to 1
and now we want to multiply the
function that we're averaging,
which in this case is x, by the
appropriate weight function.
And the weight function
is how much of the region
is associated with that x-value.
And that's the height of
this little rectangle,
which in this case is
x minus x cubed dx.
OK.
But then, this is
an average, we have
to divide by the total
weight of the region.
The weight, in this
case, is just the area.
So we have to divide
by the integral
from 0 to 1 of just
this x minus x cubed dx.
OK, so we have to compute
these two integrals
and then we have to
take their ratio.
So let's do them separately.
So the first one is--
well, the second one
is actually a little simpler.
The one in the denominator,
so let's handle that first.
The integral from 0 to
1 of x minus x cubed dx.
Well, this is a
pretty easy integral.
It's x squared over 2 minus
x to the fourth over 4
between 0 and 1.
So that's 1/2 minus 1/4
minus, well when you put in 0
you just get 0.
So that's 1/4.
And the first one,
the top, the numerator
is the integral from 0 to 1.
OK, we can multiply
through, so that's
x squared minus x
to the fourth dx.
So that integral
from 0 to 1 again
is x cubed over 3 minus x to the
fifth over 5 between 0 and 1.
When we put in 0 we get 0,
put in 1 we get 1/3 minus 1/5.
So that's common denominator 15.
2/15.
So the numerator of our
average value is 2/15,
the denominator is 1/4.
So the average value
we're interested in
is 2/15 divided by
1/4, which is 8/15.
So the average
x-coordinate is just,
so 8/15 is just a tiny
bit larger than 1/2.
So this is saying somehow the
average x-coordinate is just
slightly shifted to
the right of 1/2.
So this, I may have drawn this
region sort of symmetrically,
but in fact it's a little bit
shifted to the right there.
So that's the the first
part of the problem.
For the second part, we want
to compute the probability-- so
OK, so we choose a point
at random in this set R
and we want to know
what's the probability
that its x-coordinate
is larger than 1/2.
Well, since all points are,
you know, equally likely,
all regions, the
probability just
has to do with the
area of the region.
What we really want to know
is, what's is area of R
to the right of the
line x equals 1/2.
So that's the good
region, and then we
want to know how much of
the entire region is that.
So we want to know the
area of the good region
to the right of 1/2
divided by the total area.
Now luckily we've
already computed
the total area, right here.
This was this denominator
that we had over here.
So we just need the
numerator of that fraction.
So let's go over here,
let me write that down.
So the probability
equals-- I'm going
to put good area in
quotation marks--
so what I mean by good area is
the area of the set of points
that satisfies our condition.
And in our case, the
good area is just-- so
a point we're interested in,
if its x-coordinate is bigger
than 1/2, so we just want to
take the part of this region
to the right of 1/2.
So in order to
compute that, we just
take this integral from 1/2
to 1 instead of from 0 to 1.
So we're only counting those
points to the right of 1/2
and then we want the,
you know, the area
between these two
curves on that region.
OK, so, and again this
is a fairly simple
integral to compute.
So this gives me x squared over
2 minus x to the fourth over 4
between 1/2 and 1.
All right, so this is
maybe a tiny bit hairy,
so this gives me 1/2 minus 1/4
minus-- well we put in 1/2 here
we get 1/8 minus-- 1/2 to the
fourth is 1/16, divided by 4
is 1/64.
So this is all going
to be in sixty-fourths.
So OK.
So let's see, 32/64 minus
16/64 minus 8/64 plus 1.
If I just put it all over
that common denominator.
All right, so I think that looks
like 9/64, if I did that right.
So, OK.
So that's the good area.
And then the
probability that I want,
I have to divide the good
area by the total area.
And we saw before that
the total area was 1/4.
And that was what
this computation was.
So the total area's 1/4,
so the probability--
I'm just going to write pr
for probability-- that we're
interested in is 9/64
divided by 1/4 which is 9/16.
OK, so this says-- also 9/16
is also a little bit bigger
than a half.
So this is a different way of
saying, our region, there's
a little bit more
of it to the right
then there is to the left.
You know, so it's
slightly more likely
that a random point is
to the right of the line
y equals 1/2 than it is
to the left of that line.
So just to sum up, we had
these two different problems
that we did concerning
this region R.
So first we computed the average
value of the x-coordinate
of a point in this region.
So that was part a.
We computed the average
value of the x-coordinate,
and that was over here.
So we had to, you know, do
this, the weighted average
of the x-coordinate
divided by the total area.
And then second, we
computed the probability
that a randomly chosen point has
x-coordinate larger than 1/2.
And we did that over here.
And for that we
needed to compute
the area of the
good region, which
was the part to the right
of the line y equals 1/2
and then we needed to
divide it by the total area.
So I'll end there.